that's fascinating by the way the
astrophysical disks
how what are they how broad is this
definition
okay so astrophysical disks span
a huge uh huge amount of ranges
they start maybe at the smallest scale
they start with actually kuiper belt
objects some kuiper belt objects have
rings
okay so that's maybe the smallest
example of an astrophysical disk we've
got this
little potato shaped asteroid you know
which is
you know sort of the size of la or
something and around it
is or some rings of icy matter
that object is a small astrophysical
disk then you have
saturn the rings of saturn you have the
next set of scale you have the solar
system itself when it was forming you
have
this then you have black hole discs uh
you have galaxies disks are super common
in the universe
and the reason is that stuff rotates
right i mean gravity works yeah so uh
and those rings could be the material
that uh composes those rings could be
it could be gas it could be solid it
could be anything that's right so
the disc that made from which the
planets emerged was predominantly
hydrogen helium gas
on the other hand the rings of saturn
are made up of
you know icicles ice little like
ice cubes this big about a centimeter
across
that sounds refreshing so that's
incredible hydrogen helium gas
so in the beginning it was just hydrogen
and helium
around the sun how does that lead to the
first formations of solid
objects in terms of simulation okay
here's the story um so you're like have
you ever been to the desert
yes i've been to the death valley and
actually it was uh terrifying just
total tangent i'm distracting you but i
was uh
uh driving through it and i was really
surprised because it was
at first hot and then as it was getting
into the evening there's this huge
thunderstorm like it was raining and it
got freezing cold
like what the hell is it was the
apocalypse yeah i had to like
just sit there listening to bruce
springsteen i remember
and just thinking i'm probably going to
die and i was okay with it
because bruce springsteen was on the
radio look when you've got the boss
you know you're you're ready you're
ready to meet the ball yeah
so look i mean it's a good line so i'm
sorry
that's true um yeah by the way like
to continue on this tangent i i
absolutely love the southwest
for this reason just um
you know i know during the pandemic i
drove from la
to new mexico a bunch of times the
madness the weather
yeah the the the chaos of whether the
fact that you know it will be blazing
hot one minute and then it's just like
we'll decide to have a little
thunderstorm maybe we'll decide to
go back momentarily to like a thousand
degrees and then go back to the
thunderstorm
it's amazing it's it's that by the way
is chaos theory in action yeah
right um but let's get back to talking
about the desert
so in the desert um tumbleweeds
have a tendency to roll because the wind
rolls them
and if you're careful you'll
occasionally see this family of temple
weeds where like there's like a big one
and then there's a bunch of little ones
that that kind of hide
in its wake right and are all rolling
together and still almost looks like
you know a family of ducks crossing a
street or something
um or for example you know
if you watch tour de france right you've
got a whole bunch of cyclists
and they're like cycling you know within
10 centimeters of each other they're not
bffs right yeah but they're not yeah
trying to be
trying to write together yeah they are
writing together to minimize the
collective
uh you know air resistance if you will
that uh
that they experience turns out solids in
the protoplanetary disk do
just this um there's an instability
wherein solid particles right things
that are
a centimeter across will start to hide
behind one another and form these clouds
why because cumulatively that minimizes
the solid component of this
aerodynamic interaction with the gas now
these clouds
because they're kind of a favorable
energetic condition for the dust to live
in
they grow grow grow grow grow until they
become so massive that they collapse
under their own weight
that's how the first building blocks of
planets form that's how the
big asteroids got there that's
incredible yeah so that
is that simulatable or is it not useful
to simulate no no that's simulatable
and people do these types of
calculations it's
it's really cool that's actually that's
one
of the many fields of planet formation
theory that is really really active
right now people are trying to
understand all kinds of aspects of that
process because of course
i've explained it you know like as if
there's one
thing that happens turns out it's a
it's a beautifully rich uh dynamic but
the
but qualitatively formation of the first
building blocks
actually follows the same sequence as
formation of stars
right stars are just clouds of gas
hydrogen helium gas that sit in space
and slowly cool and at some point they
you know contract to a point where their
gravity overtakes the thermal
you know pressure support if you will
and they collapse under their own weight
we get a little baby solar system
you